-Welcome back!
-Thank you.
-This is -- This is a new show
-It's a new show, yeah.
-And that basically lays out the
premise of the show right there.
-Yes, right there.
My parents, who are baby boomers
and fun-loving,
are fiscally irresponsible
and have to move into my house
-And it's the great Fran
Drescher who plays your mother
-The great Fran Drescher.
-She was here
a couple weeks ago, and I --
-I know. I got a text messag
that was sent into
the subject matter of an e-mail.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She -- I mean, I love her,
and meeting her was,
like, sort of goosebumpy.
-Yeah, it's --
-Were you a fan of her?
-Oh, I mean, yes.
I'm a Jewish kid
from Manhattan,
so, you know, "The Nanny" --
having the Nanny play my mom
it's like being Jewish royalty
in a lot of ways.
Like, my kid's Hebrew school
they just call me,
and they're like,
"Don't worry about tickets
for the High Holidays.
The Nanny's your mom.
We got you."
-That opens doors
like that for you.
-Totally. The other day --
I didn't even know I did this.
But just from
sitting on the couch,
I got three separate cousins
three separate internships
at Condé Nast.
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Wow. Just from --
-Just from Fran Drescher
playing my mom, yeah.
-You have three children.
-I have three children.
-And you raised them
for a bit in L.A.,
and now you're raising the
in New York.
What's the difference like
for you?
-Well, you have kids
in New York.
And I feel like
now I have to do things
to, like, guard them
from the elements,
prepare them, you know, that
it's going to be cold outside.
And they don't want
to even deal with that.
-Yeah.
-Because they have lived in L.A.
And so, in L.A., I'd be like
"It's a little cold outside.
You might want to wear
a jacket." They'd be like, "No."
I'd be like, "Alright.
I don't care."
Now I'm like,
"It's cold outside.
You want to put on a jacket?
And they're like, "No."
And I'm like,
"Alright. Suit yourself."
And then as soon as we
get outside, they're like,
"It's freezing!
Why would you do this to me?!"
I'm like, "You -- Alright,
I'll go get you a jacket."
And I go get the jacket,
and I come back.
I'm like, "You want the jacket?"
They're like, "No!"
What am I doing?
But there's a lot more of that
-Yeah, seems like a part of it
that it's worse.
And then they get bossy
'cause they are New Yorkers.
-Yeah. Well, yes.
Now they tell everybody, like --
My son loves to go, "You kno
the water here? Amazing."
[ Laughter ]
He loves
that bit of information.
He loves to tell people
that the reason the pizza
and the bagels are good
is 'cause of the water.
-So, this is something that just
had its five-year anniversary.
And your co-host for this grea
moment in television history
was Ben Schwartz,
who was here last week.
-Yes.
-You were a one-night host
of "The Late Late Show"...
-Yes.
-...in the period between
Craig Ferguson doing the sho
and James Corden
taking the show over.
-Which was a very dark perio
in all of our lives.
-It was a very short
and different guest host
on different days.
-Yeah, sometimes --
It was, like, once John Maye
and once Whitney Cummings
and a bunch of very,
very established people --
Regis Philbin.
And then the last night,
I did it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And it was -- It kind of -
-It went horribly.
-Yeah.
But it's fascinating television.
I would argue
it did not go horribly.
-I would argue that, too.
-Yeah.
-Everyone else
argues against me.
-Let's show a little
of just you introducing it
and then we'll talk about it
-Oh, God.
As far as "Late Late Show"
guest hosts are concerned,
I'm an odd choice.
Not a great fit.
I've never been on CBS before.
I don't even really watch CBS.
But I do have
two living Jewish grandmothers
and a father-in-law all over 60.
So someone related to me
is always watching this network.
CBS could not give a fart
about what I'm doing.
[ Laughter ]
-So, that was basically --
And is it true --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You mentioned Whitney and Regis,
who hosted it
the same week as you.
Is it true that you flew o
the same flight out to New York?
-Yeah. We all showed up
at the airport on Monday
'cause they wanted us all
to be in New York for the week
And I realized something
was different right away
when they were, like, calling,
like, the aisles
of where you're sitting
on the plane.
And the three of us
were in a discussion.
And then the two of them
got up and went
when they said business class.
And I was like, "Oh, ri--
Oh, right.
I'll stay right here."
And then I had to walk by them
on the airplane,
all the way back,
after three minutes previous
telling them I had
the same job as them...
-Sure, yeah.
-...that they were doing.
It was really bad.
But on my way back,
Regis did yell out,
"Go get 'em!"
[ Laughter ]
Which was nice,
knowing that I was --
he meant go get 'em,
like, to row 36D.
-You, also, on top
of everything else,
the -- there was
a snowstorm that day.
-Yes. There was a blizzard
-So, you didn't have guests.
-I didn't have guests.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, I just saw thi
on the monitor.
I'm wearing the same thing
Edie Falco is wearing.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really --
Now that you mention it...
-It's the same exact thing
-...it's really close.
[ Laughter ]
-Bizarre.
-And you know what?
I feel like for certain people
in show biz,
you worry about that.
Like, "I hope I don't --"
-I didn't think about it
once today!
-Of course not!
-I was like, "I guarantee
I won't be wearing the sam
thing as Carmela Soprano."
Turns out I was dead-wrong
Also, I am giving off
a very strong vibe
that I am one of the directors
of "Uncut Gems"
that ate the other one.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a very good Safdie joke.
-It's the sole Safdie joke
You don't have to get it.
It's for me
and the Jews that run Hollywood.
[ Laughter ]
-And it's time
they get something nice,
something for them.
-It's so hard for a Jew
to break into Hollywood.
[ Laughter ]
It's just not our, you know --